well we are back
against all the odds here we are live
uh we made it dude they said not only
did they say we would never be
back they said we would never be live
again did they say anything about our
set
dude they said they would never change
the set just for
another kind of theme for the show but
here we are
you know in one week's time look what
these guys whipped up dude we got a
we got a makeshift led we got a cool ass
back lighting and we're live in a cool
dimly lit room
after dark thematic what's up
wow super excited i gotta tell you i was
out really looking forward to today
i really like these friday episodes i
mean i know we only had one but i think
it's a blast
i had a lot of fun
[Laughter]
we have a heck of a show here today
guaranteed to be
demonetized i think i'm men spreading
you you should come towards me oh for
real
thank you dude must have a big one ela
to spread that wide yeah
um the theme of of
after dark of course is that we save all
of the stuff we would have to usually
cut from our episodes
because it's going to get us demonetized
or claimed or what have you
and because of our gracious beautiful
members that are supporting us directly
we can basically just come here and
let it rip before that though we have a
special message from a friend of the
show they sent this
in for us to play yeah super nice to
them here
let me let me play this hey everyone
it's me
leafy is here i just want to say you
should become a member of the h3 podcast
it's only five dollars a month and worth
every uh
penny i put into it you should become a
member too
how do they do how do people do that
i've been seeing these all around the
internet lately
like you take a photo and you can how
what kind of freaky dark magic is this
i don't know and this is uh this is the
future so
so our discord is like popping off the
chain like we have brilliant minds in
our discord
somebody made this there right dan uh
yeah
it's a guy named cameron who's actually
a meme master
shout out to that guy he's been uh
bringing a lot of fire recently he made
the uh
the mecca gatsby is this cam grant yeah
oh what a legend yeah yeah uh actually
there was another message though from a
friend of the show
just because the membership thing is
such an important thing and our
in our community and like it's just so
we've been
tapping all of our resources to get
special messages so
uh here's another one hello everybody
it's me
killer keemstar the news today is that
it's more than worth it
to invest in the h3 podcast if you
become a member today for only five
dollars a month
you get all kinds of wonderful benefits
wow that [ __ ] is so freaky it's so nice
of him
you get all kinds of yeah it's super
nice for him to set aside his uh
all his beefs
excuse me jesus sorry about that
everybody
um well he made good on his promise to
get the teddy fresh
he's investing so it'll be his someday
making me happy what's that keemstar
i'm gonna take your kids college fund
and it's making me happy
yeah well i could see that why that
would make you happy to uh target a
one-year-old child but fair enough
you know we've got so basically you last
episode first of all how's everybody
doing how's the chat how's everybody
the chat is popping chat is popping
everything
up papa blesses thank you guys
papa bless right back broke as [ __ ] but
here's 25 dollars because i love you
guys
really nice come on probably shouldn't
do that yeah wait for the stimulus check
then give me that
just kidding obviously uh thank you very
much though
so in the last episode of the podcast
which
um many of you guys may have seen we did
a care and tier list
and there was a few cans that were too
uh not safe for life or
work or whatever that we saved for today
oh yeah okay i didn't know that
yeah i did we're dude this show
is so well integrated because i'm
serious that we would have just cut this
you would have never known about these
violent crazy carrots i mean this is one
of my favorite karen's
she was like dragged her ass was dragged
out of a store for not wearing a mask
now the story is apparently she was like
pepper spraying people before
of course it happened in long beach long
beach the oc is like
what's what's the deal with the oc in
california it's just south of los
angeles and it's like bizarro los
angeles where everyone there is like
magga magadot
i don't know it was probably all kinds
of people there
and you probably don't know what you're
talking about uh it is a generalization
but but i think it's like well we went
boating there and every
boat was like mega it depends on what
part of
well orange here's karen or oc karen
get out of here get the [ __ ] out of here
get out of here
give me my keys get out get me my chair
hands on everybody
ripped off my watch she took a she just
grabbed the bottle
off the counter give me my keys oh my
gosh
[Applause]
so i mean a woman is like an amazon
warrior
i gotta rewatch that but basically
do we like this do we like the uh the
explosion of the
the thing is like i think if you just
look at that you'll be like oh dude
you know the left celebrating violence i
think she was uh
pepper spraying people and just acting a
fool you know yeah
but look listen i i don't have very much
tolerance for these masked
truthers i don't think they have a right
to put the general public at risk like
that
no they don't and the consequences are
actually big
so so i would say in the words of uh
little little uh zan zack what do what
do we say
attaboy get out right
real quick uh correction here uh long
beach is la
county it's not actually obviously what
yeah
it's not what did you do no way it's
orange county long beach
long beach crypt orange county you
better fact-check that
long beach california dude the lbc
long beach crypt welcome i love it
because i have to do it
because uh it's it's definitely oc well
we cannot get anything right
nobody cares like what's going on
all right well see you guys
welcome look what you've done it's gone
oh man
i can't believe that i look like i'm
such an idiot
well it's on the border i mean it it
it's the next town over here
so it's the best nobody cares they're
like dude they're literally arguing
about which
cities in la county they're like wow who
cares
so somebody took her keys
my favorite she's like she's so
desperate to just grab grab onto
anything
she grabs a bottle she doesn't even know
what it is
behind right here look at this she's a
bottle
a cleaner i'm gonna squirt you
thoughts get out fell asleep little zan
um little zan little zach
little zam we need thoughts on this get
out
wow jesus all right
lil xan has taken too much xanax today
yeah
he's a little too chilled out so here's
a yacht karen
actually i haven't seen this one is this
one super violent resorts to violence
when she doesn't get her way this is one
that a lot of people said you left this
out
um this is one's okay in the comments
and stuff so uh
keep sending us the ones we left out
because we will do
part two yes we are we already have a
lot
lined up for part two because people
think
there's racist becky is that oh becky's
someone who's racist right
i guess so karen's aren't by nature
racist it's just becky's to get that
i think karen is more uh whining i need
to be mixed up yeah but
i think the lines blur they're best
friends
karen and becky yeah
there is no right for you to be here
okay karen
is it her slot
no i'm confused i have to say whenever
someone
calls someone a karen in person to their
face i don't like it
i don't like it i don't like it and it
takes away from it because
it this guy's out there trying to prove
this woman's a karen
you have to let her prove she's a
character yeah because you are being
insulting and rude and then like hard to
judge her
that way yeah you can't be self-aware
about it it needs to be it just
it can't be tarnished like that so
so this dude is losing points yeah the
minute you call someone a karen when
you're
filming you become yourself a todd oh
someone saying the guy version of karen
should be kim
kim the thing is such a weird name
and his first name is dan so i don't
know how dan did oh no i don't
know daniel well what about the whole
name daniel i don't want to do that to
daniels
okay we got you what else do you want
we're
difficult yeah but there's a lot of
drama on the high seas
the low seas really we got six feet here
we're not
six feet from ours oh get away oh
they're too close
on mother's day
so it appears that they're in a slot
next to them that they haven't
officially reserved
they're both neighbors how do you know
they haven't reserved it
because what you were saying about the
number yeah because i he i
i could be wrong about that i mean i
might be making assumptions here but
she doesn't like her there oh really
your doc
why are you like that good question
we're being so
nice to you this
is not your mortgage if you paid
more your vote here there would be no
issues sir just go to your own glory
what number this is 35. i like that
soundbite
[Laughter]
really so what's the problem with 35
that you do not book this [ __ ] slot
what is the problem
what is your name
[Applause]
so now i'm going to call the police on
you so now i'm going to have you here
with my daughters
i feel bad i don't know what's wrong
with people man
get out yeah uh
maybe he did pay for it because i mean
i don't know why i assumed i think i
read that somewhere
uh why are people like that
i guess that's what he said too it's
like why why do you have to be like oh
she's got issues
yeah but the whole family was getting
down with it
yeah that one was pretty high up there
for sure actually the both of them were
pretty high up there
and there's one more predator karen what
which sounds pretty badass
oh this is a new one right see i didn't
actually i actually saw this
so should i start from this time stamp
so
what happens is leading up to that it's
like to catch a predator
so they're texting pretending to be an
underage girl okay and she's texting
with the girl
saying that her and her husband want to
hang out
oh gross yeah and then the girl's like
i'm 17
or something and she still continues
to like invite her over even though
she said her age and they she asked her
like have you ever had sex before
stuff like that so definitely like
straight up chris hanson
territory this is actually a new one i
don't think i've ever
seen the yeah the wife who's grooming
for
to bring back to the husband that's
pretty interesting yeah
okay fantastic well i see they've got
receipts here uh they're just showing
lots of receipts
we don't need to watch all that it's
pretty long definitely
doing the the korean science oh let's
see the here's the couple
oh yeah that guy yeah you you that says
all you need to know about this there's
a few pictures of her so
it it doesn't seem like you know someone
just put up a fake photo it just
actually does look like her who the
light the
lady that shows up karen predator yeah
crain yeah
here oh she looks crazy in that photo
see google you gotta figure out okay
they say can you send a pic with three
fingers and she sends this
oh you just played yourself karen
predator
talk to me baby came in quiet then talk
to me baby
that's right well she's under age then i
don't again it's like
what's the channel i wonder if we should
say the name of the channel oh sure yeah
d
uh uh they had they have these like
groups
uh dap is a group focused on protecting
the youth from dangers online
what is the ap dads against predators oh
i wish their name was dab instead of
pete dap so they could dab on the
predators
so when when they confront them they're
like you just got dabbed on
[Laughter]
be awesome but it's okay they're trying
their best
you know not everyone has a marketing
genius
all right so uh here we go
this is exciting why do they got a groom
i
was like why do you gotta go for like a
167 trill just go on
you would have no problem finding
someone who would like to partake in
that activity right zach
like you wouldn't have to look for an
underage girl
they're saying dap is like ben shapiro's
wife
that dry ass [ __ ] i don't want to say
it
but you just did it that
we gotta we need that rap song to be
made got that dry ass [ __ ]
need that vaseline wipe
ben shapiro got that sex appeal
uh uh no [ __ ] let's just move on
how's it going i think you know why we
feel like i've known people like her i
can cause a scene if you don't want to
be honest
we're dads against predators okay you
just got dabbed on
me well i'm glad you're here
right because the only reason i came
down was the right people
oh yeah yeah what's the what i have to
wipe the phone
so she comes up with the dumbest excuse
she apparently asked the girl to come in
anyway because she wanted to wipe the
phone
maybe wow no sense well it's really an
admission of guilt because she's like
she's like yeah they're just like yeah i
gotta wipe my phone dude
cause you're doing something wrong
wasn't she
because i don't understand why you
wouldn't just go for somewhere i thought
you wanted her to have fun with your
husband and you were scared she was a
cop
no that's what you said yeah so that you
could come so i could wipe your phone
because
why would you want to wipe his phone you
knew she was you knew
how old she was you kept on saying i'm
scared i i don't want the cops to come i
don't want to get in
then this is not the time for this kind
of captivity i mean
that's not exactly cool i don't think
it's cool to meet up with children
look how beautiful then this is
let me speak okay i'll let you speak i'm
sorry
that's why if you're not getting yeah no
i see the the the
crossover bring her up there
should i watch this whole thing how good
does this go
it's the same thing more of that she
just doesn't let go let me skip ahead
because i'm surprised they talked for so
long i would just bail i was like okay
you got me
you know what i mean they'd stay there
you got me i was trying to
[ __ ] a kid you know
look how beautiful she is that's just
very good that's
ridiculous why would you ask her
whatever what have you done with the
child like what have you done with the
girls why would you ask her then
i wasn't meaning to ask her that who was
meaning to ask
i was meaning to ask somebody else oh he
accidentally sent that
actually i can show you how many
different girls i've already asked that
okay so how many of them are underage
[Music]
[Music]
luck without that but all right i'm over
it yeah
pretty epic
we got any donation don't knows anything
to to
read off i don't want to uh yeah i don't
want to neglect our good
uh fair supporters here uh
you look healthy as [ __ ] inspired me to
try the feeding window
how has that been treating you how's
that been treating you well
are you even doing the window i was for
for a minute i was doing the feeding
window which was like i had like a six
hour feeding window
yeah it was going good for a minute but
like here's what happened
when i fell into what you went out the
door i walked out
never looked back i went for 40 ounces
and never returned
uh here's what happened is like i was
doing it for two weeks and then
it was hard but i was really committed
and i stepped on the scale
and i lost like you know two
three pounds and i was like dude
i was like i'm so disappointed that
that's all i've lost
that being said i wasn't committed i
wasn't exercising
and i was kind of like during that
window
i was going a little window wild
so i don't think i did it well right
holy [ __ ] bro oh yeah
but i really want to i'm just dude i
hate being fat so much and i'm just
i really want to to lose weight i feel
like
i don't want a trainer you should get a
trainer i don't like
trainers why not because it's like they
just tell you to do the [ __ ] you already
know it's just just by peer pressure
pressure is the important part okay no
run run around the building it's like
okay cool but are you doing
no do a push-up it's like i could have
done all that at home but
but you don't it's like a whole schlep
you get you go to the trainer then they
tell you
okay now what you need to do now what
you need to do
is do 10 push-ups i'll be like oh dude
that's
epic that he told me to do 10 push-ups
first of all i just want to say that
you're actually getting um compliments
kendra said that you're more attractive
now than ever
because i'm oh oh that's a lady
yeah ila does not share that opinion and
frankly i don't blame her you should see
me with my shirt off kendra
i don't i look like a tub of butter
it's not that simple i just i do want
you to get
healthier and you can think that it's
an excuse but i truly think that you
should get healthier
right now there's nothing first of all i
know that you're i know that
that's your but there's nothing wrong
with saying look dude you're fat and i
don't want to [ __ ] you
i wouldn't say you know what ela said
she said the other day
because we're trying to get pregnant
again and so you can imagine
a lot of fornicating oh i have a feeling
you didn't understand me i already know
where you're going
and she said to me dude you gotta lose
weight because oh that i have back pain
because you're so fat and you mount me
that might be the sign yeah no i i took
that seriously
i took that seriously is is there like a
certain position that
increases your chances of getting
pregnant more no i don't think that's
[ __ ]
but um great let's share everything
well it's just a funny anecdote you know
it's relevant to uh what we're talking
about i think you should get a trainer
hate it all you want that's the purpose
they make you exercise right now you're
not exercising
okay dude no you're gonna do ten
uh jumping jacks exactly
i've been and then you do it i'm gonna
it's gonna happen
and everyone's gonna be super proud of
me and fantasizing
just donated 50 said bro go to a trainer
i was skeptical like you but it works
oh thank you for 50 bucks on me yeah
thank you for the donation he's just
paid for my first now you have to
thank you man now you're obligated well
i'll tell you i went to a trainer i've
done i've tried it before
like years ago yeah yeah no i tried it
and
i mean it's good but like the whole
schlep of it of like going and then
they can come back so okay dude
here's what we need to do today we're
gonna do one pull-up
run around the house and then do 20
jumping jacks
great i'll be like [ __ ] you i can do
that i don't need you here
what was the last time you done that
never last time i had a trainer
imagine you get all yolk though like
yolked ethan
what's that like you get all shredded
looking all yolked
i'm not gonna get dreaded uh that will
never happen i want him too
but i it's but i would like to lose a
lot of weight
you know i look back at my old videos
when i was um a fair bit skinnier and
i'd be like
i'd suck his dick
[Laughter]
yeah yeah but what's what's weird is
that even then
i thought i was fat
yeah that is weird because now when i
look at it too you look totally skinny
yeah it looks super like good and
healthy you know
it's funny how that is i think um
there's a lot of requests for that air
or maybe it's just the same person
how many people we got why are you going
to put all these people through dead air
i mean as soon as i said it i realized
maybe it's just the same person you want
me just one
it's the one guy he's asked like 200
times okay no dead air bro you go go
watch
static we got a 50 donation from ryan
kelly who said
we better be seeing mayo on dan's dome
today
first of all thank you for the 50
donation we've been talking a lot about
this we're definitely going to get
mayo on dan's dome it's just a matter of
when you just put 50 on it yeah do you
not care about our fans
wasted your money bro oh my goodness
stop don't be rude
well he dan said he'd do it for charity
uh yeah i guess
like if we raise like a huge uh it's
just so
you guys are you're you're over hyping
it it's not going to be that good
it's not going to be worse zach had a
bunch of hair
it was hilarious because it got all
stuck no but you have a no
you have this weird mayonnaise version
it's up to us
to enjoy it and we will enjoy it yeah
it'll be amazing
sorry guys i got this anyway
your garf your garfield or what did you
call it
oh my my gerds gerds your drinks
it's what you call the acid reflux
disease that i have
gerd gang i got to do something with the
gerd gang
right is that can someone fact check me
on that gerd it is gerd yes
what does it stand for uh gastric
we got another 50 donation
gastroesophageal reflux disease gang
good game how many of my peeps in the
chat got that
girl gert is hard as [ __ ]
oh my god i'm sorry i'll be just so
oh what's going on man there's a lot of
requests for
trisha moses update well
all right i'm just gonna let the should
i just get should i just build the beans
trish and moses should i just spill the
[ __ ]
wait what kind of bin the big beans no
you don't want to spill the big bean you
can i can't take the garbanzo bean
but we're gonna have trisha on soon but
they're actually doing well i have to
say
it seems like they're happily dating
that they're actually just a couple
and so i just kind of i'm been forced to
accept that
i don't know if this is so happy for
them i just i think the biggest problem
was
the confusion around everything the
whole time
the secrecy the confusion yeah we're
right moses kept
denying it to you guys right and then
yeah he would say yeah he would go we're
just friends and then all of a sudden
they make a tick tock together where
she's voicing a 12 year old girl
you remember that [ __ ] that's so weird
and moses is like daddy
disciplining 12 year old i mean
anyway they're dating so i'm happy
they actually sound really cute together
it's crazy
yeah i have to admit that there's some
weird actual chemistry between the two
of them
somehow she's going to come on we're
going to talk about it in more detail
but when he told us we realized
season 2 worked out again
that's the epiphany the bachelor is so
far
100 successful
you never know what's gonna happen on
this show think about it
ian is now dating sam who moved cross
country to be with him
they lived together now moses
and trisha this is a love connection
that would have
never happened in a billion years but
through the magic of
the h3 bachelor we've we've forged
two successful impossible loves
clap those cheeks yeah
so i think that's pretty exciting
but we're gonna have her on we're gonna
talk about it and uh
there's actually some really other
exciting news but these guys are saying
i can't announce it
well you gotta live some stuff
show your whole hand no why not
they're saying no they're vetoing guys
sorry but you'll find out soon enough
but it's good it's exciting
oh my god this is
unwatchable the gerd man
all right what else we got um h3
all-star can i watch this or is this
i mean i guess we can [ __ ] it
what is that is this good the h3
all-star cover i mean
it's what you think it is all right
here we go history podcast forever
[Music]
[Music]
is
you'll never know that far off
[Applause]
i think it's a good remix we started
really strong and it was very impressive
it was
so it's actually related to the news now
right oh yeah we have a news story about
that um
which is out of order but here it is so
we goofed on
a smash mouth shrek mouth
because they were at the sturgis biker
gang
not a biker game just a biking
convention
i assume everyone who's on a bike is a
dangerous criminal
so they played at the show they screamed
[ __ ] covet and all that well
you gotta love it sturgis show connected
to over a hundred covid 19
cases and now sturgis is a coveted hot
spot
oh my god hey now you've got covid
i saw someone say um i ain't the
sharpest tool in the
shed yeah right that's a lyric man
i ain't the sharpest tool in the shirt
well i was coughing in the crowded
sturgeon
by the way imagine risking your life to
see smash mouth like holy damn
it's smash mouth dude the shrek guys
there's all kinds of funny comments
somebody once told me kovid was gonna
roll me
i ain't the sharpest tool in the shed
while she was looking kind of dumb with
her several symptoms
a cough fatigue and burning forehead
oh he's got the whole thing well her
breath stops coming and the coughs keep
coming federer no rules and i ignore
what the state's well
fed has no rules so i ignore the states
while humming why are you reading tweets
oh let's show oily did it make sense not
to live for
fun my mask is half off because my brain
is dumb
kovid for you for me it's inevitable so
let's go to the beach
we'll never know because we won't test
we'll never ventilate because we won't
rest yeah
i just started you think mine was i
might do mine
oh my god um somebody donated 250 uh
czar i don't know what that was did you
just give me czars
currency let's see azar is a south
african
rand so a south african dollar
essentially
so how what is that i don't know i
didn't do the conversion but well why
tell me how much what is the message
well i want to know how much it is maybe
it's just a dollar fifty
i mean okay okay star killer came
through
it's fifteen dollars okay thank you very
generous but but
more importantly he said dan should mail
up that dome
if ethan reaches his weight loss goal
dan
and uh i could agree to that so what is
my goal i would mail my dome
whoa everyone males they're dumb yeah
but i gotta share bed with you that's
not that great you're gonna stink like
mayo and i gotta sleep next to you
we gotta get out of zac's hair
eventually yeah
okay so what's the goal that's gonna
hate it
what's the goal what is your goal well
there's like too crazy where are you at
right now
dude like 220. so let's get down
i mean 200. get if you can get below
200.
i mean like my real big goal is like 170
that's what i used to be like back in
israel
190. no one no no 200. okay 200 for the
mail about
below 200 let's make it that no no no
1.99 don't move the bar
you said 200. all right let's under 200
undertook
another 50 donation from the comedy crew
dan get that mayo well there's a lot of
movement for this so
it's 200. robin is asking me if it's a
problem when ethan coughs in public
it doesn't happen that much actually but
we always wear a mask so
i hate it i mean i i i listen back and
it's like unwatchable these [ __ ]
it really got worse lately i don't know
it's a new thing that we need to figure
out why it's happening
like i do i just need to get up and walk
out of the room when i cough because i i
don't want this to be unwashable for
everybody who's like dude i can't i
don't want to listen to some dude call
for
three hours um
i'm just gonna i'm just gonna get up and
walk out
what were we talking about um so what is
your goal
200 200 200.
dan okay if you get under or no fine at
200.
i'm effectively saying the same thing
i'm saying 199 yeah but that's a big
precipice don't [ __ ] one extra pound
don't take anything away from me
you could totally do two uh 21 pounds
you could totally do that all right zach
you want to lose it for me
i would if i could actually exactly
1999
[Laughter]
once i get to 200 i'll set up another
milestone
you can get to 200 and i will mail yeah
okay how about this dan
200 and then if i get below two if i get
to
180 you have to cov you have to put on
the speedo and cover your whole body in
mayo
no i would never agree to that why not
[Laughter]
we're dropping the three it's just h
the eight show the h will be that air
show
the a stands for dead air and we'll see
about that i think we'll get i mean
we're gonna if my goal is to get dan in
a kiddie pool covered in mail that's not
gonna happen
dude even if i lose 50 [ __ ] pounds
maybe
um wow
i agree we why are you already trying to
raise the bar
on one goal at a time yeah okay wait if
dan if he
if he loses 50 pounds he wouldn't get in
a pool of mayonnaise yeah
how about you do it of course that's
fine i would absolutely
do that all right he's gonna get in a
speedo and he'll get into a kiddie pool
you really don't think zach would do
that
i don't think he'll do it he will do it
too no but it has to be damp
you and i gets get some men's thongs
[Laughter]
[ __ ] shave the ass cheeks all that
[ __ ] man um
a lot of people are saying the coffee is
part of your
brand so don't worry no but like i'm
telling you like
the last episode we did it was the um
i talked about it you know we just
filmed a podcast with cody cole
sorry to caillou but um joshua is saying
if
bro if you lose weight you won't get all
the
the gerd yeah it could help because the
fat puts a lot of pressure on my stomach
you snore at night ethan no i don't
snore i i breathe perfectly fine
very silent sleeper yeah
dan set me up a kill button so when i
cough i push the kill button
but eli didn't have one so what was
happening is like
i was coughing way more than i usually
would because i would hit the kill
button i'd be like
but then elo's mic was picking it up
like totally fine we sit so close we
didn't realize like
it will just yeah on mine but i just saw
a lot of comments of people like
this this is unwatchable the dude's just
coffee and i'm like you're right
i listened to it and i was like this is
horrible so you guys are generous but
like you guys are also
the more dedicated viewers let's be
honest
so thank you guys for the forgiveness
but at the end of the day
you know gerd gang oh i should introduce
um
a b don't you think yeah just real quick
i'm seeing
i guess uh i think the stream dropped
out for a second or something
people were saying f because i think the
stream started lagging or something
but i think it's back yeah people are
saying they're back
it looks like it on eli's computer yeah
it's live on my computer so
i don't know everybody's typing f is
that
uh something yeah okay they're saying
we're good now rest in peace but the the
youtube the way that they encode it is
genius because
it just okay we're good i think we're
good yeah people are saying it's bad
okay so uh
abs with us here let me pull up zoom so
i can talk to him
we got a new uh crew member with us
oh god zoom is so annoying with this
like little floaty [ __ ] i can't get out
oh let me just click this all right av
just uh say hi hello
so a b is joining us um we're stepping
up our episode
edge and we are yeah i can't i don't
know
it's right here but i can't drag it oh
there it goes thank you
let's see we're stepping up our episode
age to be honest with you guys we're
doing three a week now but
for a week is right around the corner
and um
that's what's up dude four per week
so starkiller here as some of you may
know him
but av we've talked about him before
yeah he's just sam
starkiller are you age three i i am i'm
obviously number one simp are you though
because i know you're fans of other
youtubers
like just be totally honest which one
who's your favorite youtuber and don't
you don't have to lie and say it's me
uh no it's it's between you and casey
neistat i think
it was kind of even but now i'm leaning
towards you guys well i gave you a job
it better be
i'm kidding i'm playing what do you love
so
what do you love about casey um
just i don't know he's uh his content i
feel like he's actually a revolutionary
of a genre
definitely yeah yeah he's a super talent
he's a freak of nature sure
he doesn't sleep he does like a million
things in one day
he sleeps for three hours yeah you do
that don't tell me you do that because
of casey
no no no i've always been that way my
parents don't sleep and
i'm a lot worse than them so really runs
in the family yeah are you sl you're not
sleepy all the time
no i mean now that i'm getting a little
older i start to feel it a little bit
more but when i was younger i could go
a day or two without yeah didn't bother
me at all
is it cause trouble in your relationship
because you are married
uh you don't sleep i mean it's gotta be
odd not to be on the same cycle
no thankfully uh lina she's a heavy
sleeper so i don't wake her up in the
middle of the night so
it's and i'm up whenever she wakes up
i'm a light sleeper too so if i hear
anything i'll wake up
that sounds it's always like a blessing
and a curse do you wish that you slept
normally
are you happy you do i definitely wish
yeah
oh i hate it does it just get lonely in
the middle of the night what do you hate
about it
um yeah i mean yeah it's i mean i'm
definitely exhausted a little bit now
i'm like i said i'm feeling it more but
yeah it does get lonely a little bit and
i feel bad making so much noise and i
can't do anything but
wow i am productive though nice
because like the night hours for me or
the is the best time to work or do
anything creative like the dude doesn't
sleep
[Music]
[Laughter]
trying to find the good in it he's
miserable look at him
people on the discord are calling me
sexy baby oh thank you
he's married guys he is taken so yeah
well abe uh he basically sent me some
research when we were just casually
talking and i was really impressed so
i said hey you want to come uh you're
looking for a job because we needed
another person basically for
specifically that so here he is he just
joined
and uh we'll be seeing more of a b
the insomniac oh also thank you for
having me
credit to him uh he helped out uh
setting up all these lights
yeah he did so if you're digging the the
color scheme we got here
uh that was his contribution absolutely
thank you dan glad to be part of the
team you guys are all
very uh very surreal but you guys are
all very sweet and you guys helped me
feel very welcome
and i appreciate it that'll be here
don't worry
i'm just gonna ask you would you get in
that pool of mayonnaise with a thong on
would you do it i'd do anything for
ethan
so that's yeah that'll be interesting to
test his limits as we
as we've been i'll do anything zach does
how about that yeah because
i know that zach's a ride or die yeah
and it's easy to say that
maybe but we'll see as as the show
progresses
we haven't asked ian what did what would
the end do with mayonnaise ian would do
nothing did he ends up
in i mean ian would you get in a pool
with mayonnaise for
50 pounds of weight loss wait why would
i do that
well that's not the premise i don't know
for our blazer yeah just what is the
benefit of it it's entertainment dude
we're a show we entertain people you're
supposed to suffer and we're supposed to
have fun watching
i mean i'm cool you said that's a no
that sounds like maybe if i like if we
all said our
if we all had weight loss goals and then
each other all had to jump in mayo
i would do it i mean i would do it of
course
show off my beautiful new body all right
let's get rid of you guys
love you guys thank you i did not like
it
no of course not um
so oh this this is a flop that i
definitely couldn't show in our normal
episode um this guy
this was one right which one is this
this is the guy who says a
anti-gay slur while live on a hot
yeah right so the premise is that
he's an announcer for the
reds and
he thinks his mics off but it's on and
he says something really horrific about
gay people
and then during the same game he gets
fired
and he gives up an apology during the
same game wow
and what's funny to me is he keeps
announcing during his apology
and then he's just bounce it's crazy man
i never see anything like this
in the world
he said it very hatefully too live the
pregame
the [ __ ] capitals of the world
red's live the free game
[Music]
maybe just don't even say that yeah you
know path for the fifth inning
castellanos to lead things off jim day's
gonna be taking us the rest of the way
through this game as holland takes over
on the mound
um i made a comment earlier tonight
that i guess went out over the year that
i am deeply
ashamed of if i have hurt anyone out
there
i can't tell you how much i say from the
bottom of my heart i'm so very very
sorry
i pride myself and think of myself as a
a man of faith because there's a drive
in a deep left field by castilla
i mean listen you don't want to miss the
play they're like dude
but they're probably like they're like
dude you gotta wrap it up
they're like you gotta get out of there
now they just they dropped him like
so fast i've never seen anything like it
they couldn't even wait till the end of
the game i mean look at this is the uh
oh the fifth so like yeah it took half
the game basically
right he still now so that'll make it a
four-nothing
ball four-nothing game i said i am a man
of faith
i said something that was deeply
offensive
high fly ball i don't know if i'd be
putting on this headset again
i don't know if it's going to be for the
reds i don't know if it's going to be
for my bosses at fox i want to apologize
for the people who sign my paycheck
for the reds for fox sports ohio for the
people i work with
for anybody that i've offended here
tonight i can't begin to tell you how
deeply sorry i
am that is not who i am uh and never has
been
so it was just 30 minutes ago
i can i can kind of relate where it's
like
i think i know what he's i i do feel
kind of bad for him like his
life just got totally [ __ ] ruined
from one and it was a
by the way a horrible thing to say but
sometimes
you just have these moments of clarity
at the worst time
because sometimes you'll be at a party
and you'll say something like that but
the guy's old i mean she knows better
this isn't a young man
in broadcast it's like you gotta break
in front of your face good point
i mean it's not something you would just
say no not even if we weren't live you
know what i mean
you just don't really say that no
but like
maybe he's me and in his mind he's like
this is only something i would say to my
closest friends who know i'm not hateful
in my heart
maybe but like maybe upon
self-reflection he's like
it takes some time to be like damn i
shouldn't be saying that at all
yeah and he got he i don't maybe i'm
giving it to i mean
the dude's life just got ruined yeah
high
fly ball
but either he's still calling the game
it's so good
either way it's epic and i'd like to
think maybe i could have some people
that uh
they could back that up everyone's like
nah dude
i am very very sorry you know how hard
it is to get a job announcing baseball
that's like one of the most competitive
least
amount of people doing it like
opportunities to do it
dude yeah i fly ball
trying to see if there's an update
because i see that he was suspended
oh interesting but i don't see any
update since a week
ago so i'm not sure if he's fully fired
or suspended or what yeah
i think that's a see you later forever i
mean it seems like people are saying
they think he is a hateful person
oh they know him okay so so
again lots of bi dogs
uh here's a list here's something
special for you guys
uh this one's dedicated to dan
to me too yeah okay you know why zach
yeah
i get it i want to talk about feet
now is your time dude was just cruising
and piled over and look what he saw man
oh you know it's crazy i gotta go back
look at the girls not she's just
browsing her phone she i thought she was
recording maybe but she's just on her
phone
she's like on twitter
he's eating that [ __ ] like a subway
sandwich bro
who's supposed to be enjoying it she
already him dude look you see the way
he's devouring that thing you think
she's getting any pleasure in that it's
like browsing facebook
yeah i think he probably even paid her
oh what yeah they're in a gas station oh
my god
yeah he definitely paid her for that i'm
into it
that's probably a really good gig for a
prostitute just like you once took my
feet cool
wow i'll browse twitter
bro what you doing
ah that's one of the greatest greatest
greatest
i almost got a lot yeah i love how
disengaged she is with it
oh my god doing bro what you doing
oh wait this is like a service vehicle
look there's lights on top
he's like a government employee
crazy
hey you know what he's not hurting
anyone he's just sucking toe yeah yeah
that's not kink shame here
you can even suck tell him public it's
not necessarily i don't even think it's
illegal
i'm into it back then i kind of i'll to
be honest i kind of want a subway
sandwich now gross
i'm not kidding that is insane
you made me hungry i
i'm pretty close to puking and i never
even puke
so the fact that that made me made you
hungry
there's something wrong i want a subway
sandwich spicy italian with mayonnaise
you need a trainer
[Laughter]
does that sound good right now no okay
sounds fantastic right now yeah exactly
you know you're just thinking about toes
no i i
just i saw he was when i said subway
sandwich i was like
that's what i want know your way around
some meat
y'all um is there any donors to read or
members to think there's a hundred
dollar one from jacqueline
cody podcast uh leaves it all
and goes to the pool oh because she
wasn't there okay
right and then a fifty dollar wait what
did she say she said uh cody pocos
podcast ila leaves and it all goes to
the pool
what does that mean it all goes to the
pool i think his expression like it goes
to [ __ ]
oh well come on it wasn't that bad was
it no it wasn't bad at all
oh these chairs are squeaky dan
wait i just realized we've been
squeaking the whole time can you hear it
uh i don't know audience have you been
hearing the squeeze listen to this [ __ ]
i gotta change chairs
we gotta throw these out can you hear
this
now i'm concentrating on it
okay
are you getting the chairs okay ethan
went to eat he's eating
[Music]
do you see what i'm talking about
there's a problem here
all right in the meantime i'm going to
read a few more donations we got uh
they don't hear the squeak season yeah
nobody's saying they heard it at all
okay but uh we got a 25
donation from miguel hey big fan of you
guys i don't care what other people
think about you i'll always support you
too that is very sweet thank you thank
you
50 where did all the bell delphine stuff
end up
uh also can we see that simp sign lit up
somewhere it's actually sitting
right all this stuff is here oh you know
what i found out that sim sign was in
her famous music video
oh it was in the background of it also
it was actually a historical prop she
sent us
50 from antonio i use a technique to
wipe my butt that you've almost
certainly never
heard of before what i think it's a game
changer i'll be happy to explain it to
you all if you're interested get them on
get them on this card now
what could it be and i'm over 18. get
him
on now jesus
uh steep uh steep garbage is the garbage
yeah if you want to see if you can find
a man get him
on all right bringing him in now hold on
okay get him on
uh while he's queueing that up uh by the
way seventy dollar one love you guys dan
get that mayo
get that mayo dan it's gonna happen it's
up to me now though
fifty dollars hey guys we're a huge fan
of yours we are video game music cover
band from around
from rhode island our new fall guys
music video is over on our youtube
has some slick teddy fresh in it and
that's lame genie
so uh check it out everybody thank you
lame genie appreciate the uh
buckaroonies uh huge shout out to ian
zack and dan for keeping h3 afloat
giving us a lot of credit i don't know
keeping
well you guys do a lot i mean you know
especially we're ramping up the episodes
and
i mean we're not gonna lie it's been a
busy week it's been a very busy week
uh and i just moved oh i just moved that
guy into the chat can you hear me
steve okay hang on hang on hang on
who do we have how's it going um
my name is antonio okay and uh
so antonio antonio says he's got a
unique wiping technique
that we've probably never heard of so
all my friends think i'm crazy for this
and uh i feel like uh this is a good
platform to maybe see if there's anybody
else in the world
uh that does the same so
okay so my i know you guys are kind of a
connoisseur of ass hygiene if you will
um is it coming so loud i see someone
said
yeah okay sorry
yeah no worries go ahead um okay
so the way i see it there's like
two categories there's like surface
hygiene and there's inner hygiene right
there's there's the hot you don't you
want you want clean on the surface but
you also want
clean where the sun don't shine okay
so that digging in there i mean i follow
but what's the technique
okay so the technique i'm getting to it
i'm getting to it first of all setting
the stage
i stand up i'm i'm a standing up kind of
guy
and i'm from the back so already i'm i'm
in pretty stark contrast to you ethan
but that's
okay yeah but that seems like a
relatively normal way to walk
here we go so what you got to do is
after you're done with the surface
cleanliness yeah you bloop about
a half an inch maybe a little more of
your finger
into the into the pit of despair
you so you're standing up straight and
then
once it's in you bend at the waist
downward and it induces a torque you
don't
want to why i 100 do that and let me
tell you why because if what are you
going to do just like scoop it it
doesn't work
the twisting motion is what really gets
you no
you don't do that you're bullshitting us
100
i swear i swear
why are you concerned with cleaning the
inside of your colon to what benefit is
that
it's not my colon i'm not like sticking
my whole well
inside your [ __ ] i mean why do you
need to clean inside your [ __ ]
because i don't want to get itchy ass
dude that's like dude you get
you get itchy ass by fingering your
[ __ ] dry with toilet paper
oh oh look at me i'm eating i've got a
fancy bidet
i don't have these dude i didn't
the bidet is relatively new and i'm
trying to
i'm trying to educate you on this new
technique maybe it'll help the people
because first you stand up straight and
then you bend at the waist downward and
then
that that maybe twists it
counterclockwise
and then you start bent and you stand up
straight and it twists it both
directions
are you using are you using toilet paper
or baby wipes
how can
i'll tell you what's wrong with this
toilet paper on the finger
yeah this doesn't add up to it i'm sorry
this story doesn't make sense
how could toilet paper endure that much
friction
well you got it you got a layer you got
to give a couple layers you're not going
to go like
that you could you're going into your
[ __ ] with several layers
this doesn't make sense bro let me ask
you if you're if you're
washing a car are you going to like just
go up and down or you're going to do
like a circular motion
it's that twisting that really gets it
clean
dude okay let me ask you this when you
wash your car let me ask you this
when you wash your car do you clean all
way up the tailpipe
no it doesn't matter well no
well i don't have to deal with feeling
all the way up the tailpipe of my car
i don't know if i believe you dude but i
i i
promise you and i wanna i wanna know if
there's anybody
else out there that does this i mean the
chat is all saying you're lying
i mean dude i think i'll just go out on
a limb and say
if you're telling the truth you might be
the only one dude
how long have you been wiping that way i
i
maybe started doing it a few years ago
um
and it you know it solved it solved all
of my wiping problems
so what does your finger ever smell no
no i washed my hands thank you very much
let me ask you what was the necessity
for
going in there and scooping and turning
and twisting and all that and twerking
well because if you if you don't get the
dookie from the inside it's still in
there
bro you know that's where it belongs
that's your [ __ ]
i mean that's not a problem i'm
surprised but but if it works for you
man
people are saying get him off
i will say well i will say this before
we uh
before we drop you okay
thank you for the call i think it's i'm
always interested in hearing all the
different
techniques so i do thank you for calling
in and sharing that night
and i am excited to hearing other
techniques if they're out there but
don't lie to me i would never lie to you
all right thank you i believe you all
right thank you for calling right thank
you
that guy's such a [ __ ] liar
[Laughter]
no i i mean he sounded serious but it
just seems a little fun
the thing is when you if you d like
going in with one is enough because i
when you i've there was a bit of a time
in my life where you kind of scoop in
there a little bit you really don't need
to do that
but like to plug to super layer it and
scoop that seems
that doesn't seem right what do the
people think do you think he's lying
the the chat overwhelmingly seem to say
that he's lying but there's
i mean a few i see i believe him he's
not lying
i give him a no yeah some people are
saying twist gang they're part of this
game
twist gang gerd gang
well i think i believe him you believe
it zach
yeah zach probably done it you are the
most gullible
member of the cast
so what do we got here yeah i really
have to pee can you just take over elo
man i have to pee too but i'm holding it
well i can't hold it just piss yourself
it's all good uh there's a bathroom
right here
just read don't hate me i don't know
talk to the chat donations what do we
got here
um so i'm professional i named this
method the tony twist
that's pretty good that guy's name is
uh if you think that's disgusting you
should listen to what people
in rural india do i i don't know i don't
know if we can
talk about that uh let's see what else
we got here
um there were some teddy fresh questions
like one asked about this shirt
it will come out later i think next
month
maybe oh soon it's pretty soon
yeah it's not uh sometimes you wear
stuff it's like oh yeah this will be out
in a year so
yeah um have ethan search for
2018 mr olympia on youtube and give his
reaction to professional bodybuilders on
stage it would be hilarious to see his
reaction to these guys uh
i'm assuming that's like the crazy uh
mr olympia oh yeah right that's like
what uh
that's what arnold was right yeah uh
okay uh it's wild let's see
the super chats i [ __ ] hate this it's
like con anytime
a new one comes in it bumps it around so
i'm like trying to click and it makes it
real
difficult all right jacqueline to be
clear my poo comment
was about the amount of chat
debating the front and back wiper it was
a pun
nothing but love for you guys oh well i
think the problem was was that
you had a typo you said pool not poo oh
oh
that comment yeah um i know you didn't
you said pooh
all right forgive me jacqueline we did
with ethan wanting to do more
episodes um i'm just gonna have to not
be in all of them
because i do have to attend study fresh
so
yeah you guys don't realize how that
works time is occupied by that
so that's just gonna it's gonna be a new
reality
but i think that's kind of nice too to
have a variety
oh we're gonna have a variety so we've
got carton arc
we've got uh pocket [ __ ] review
oh this is someone from discord that
uses a pocket [ __ ] no hey guys welcome
to review
no no no i watched it it it wasn't as
good as as i was hoping
because i thought it was real but the
guy's joking oh yeah
okay i'm gonna ask if we would like them
to get on and tell us about their heart
tran transplant story
that sounds pretty interesting yeah
sure yeah i'd love to hear about a heart
transplant that sounds incredibly
uh sounds incredible uh tf scrubs for
the nurses
that's interesting can you wear whatever
you want like
like can it be color blocked or can
there be logo logo on it
i don't know what's the uh
that's a good question so you should we
do carton arcs i feel like this is
safe for like a normal app you know what
i mean like this is good stuff
the carton arc all praised the carton
our could be somebody just asked
uh if the episodes without ela can dan
sit next to ethan well
for one i'm i'm running the the yeah
when he's actually doing stuff i'm doing
stuff and and two uh even though i'm
here with them uh we're staying
distanced and everything because i'm
trying not to give them covet
so uh probably uh can't really sit over
there
so um this was a clip we've been wanting
to watch forever
and we've just always not included it
because we're like well this is
like a dude dying i mean it's not
graphic or grim
or you don't see anything but it it's
weird too because it's also like
hilarious
so you're very conflicted because it's
like a dude dies but it's also
like somehow funny that's the ones that
we were like we can't watch
yeah do we know for sure this person
died i
remember reading that and maybe one of
you guys can fact check that
we don't know for sure i don't think we
do no i think i think i read he died
should we i know this is the after dark
but that's still just a comment well it
doesn't it doesn't
show i mean you don't see him any
there's not graphic in any way it's just
i think i read an article that he died i
yeah he died
he died
but i know but i'm saying it's weird
because wait till you see the clip
um it's a hell of a clip and that's what
after dark's all about
yeah you know you tell me if this is
funny or not
it's very bizarre so let's go ahead and
watch i mean look at the title it's
called
mobility scooter elevator fail epic
well i guess it's funnier when you
realize he didn't die but when you watch
it
you're like oh he died for sure but here
you just go ahead and watch and
try not to laugh challenge
neither papa john laughs
elevator
uh going down
but this homie uh he
is not cool with missing the ride
and he'll be god damned if that elevator
takes off
without him and it's hard to even
explain
what he was thinking yeah he just goes
alright
see you later you see it is funny
i mean it's just so stupid like it
reminds me of that scene from
uh willy wonka where the sh they have
that good egg bad egg
for verruckle assault the way it
happened it's like
and then the door closes on him like
nothing happened
but the he see he he had a chance to
back out because
he rams it once where he doesn't go in
but you should be like
[ __ ] that's terrifying but he's like nah
dude today's a good day to die
bye see you later
oh my god wait back it up show one more
time
yeah i mean is it funny or tragic i
guess it's both
i couldn't help but laugh but it's a
mixed reaction here
is he suicidal i mean is he trying to
die
i mean there's really no way at that
point i would be terrified
but it's almost like he holds the gas on
too because watch he's like
he goes and then he's like see ya
jesus you know
hell of a ride huh wow it's like harold
and mod so
actually people are saying we've shown
this already that's what i thought i
thought we showed it
i said you guys haven't we shown this
and they all said no we cut it out
i swear i knew we showed this i thought
we did
cut it out i thought yeah didn't we cut
it i mean people are saying we should
clearly not wow
some show this is
[Laughter]
uh this guy throws trashman at sleeping
dude
recommended from uh discord by
nico what what
what are they doing some homie just fell
asleep on the john
why would you even look over i guess
it's probably because they were wanting
to take a [ __ ] or something and then oh
my god
imagine you're at work and you're like i
got a dump somebody's in there you come
back in 20 minutes it's still
you look under the stall there's feet
but they haven't seemed to move
you just see some dudes
[Laughter]
i've been that tired man i could see
myself doing that in a previous life
oh this sounds brutal i think i've seen
this one's actually almost just
violent and not funny or interesting
i've seen this one it's horrific
you can tell what's about to happen a
forklift
right here and girl on bike riding
right into it it's not it's horrific oh
i'm pretty sure she got like
gg'd as well wait but the dude falling
down the elevator shaft is not horrific
well you don't you're not
seeing i feel like the fact that
also i can't see the impact also i feel
like this is not her fault
that dude literally just uh
you know peaced out on this road yeah
fair enough fair enough
more intention behind that i don't think
i'm gonna watch it you guys
yeah it's not really funny it's just
more i'm out
i'm out we're skipping oh here's an
interesting trend
okay so tick tock continues to d uh to
not make sense to me in any way but
there's this new trend on tick tock
where people cosplay as holocaust
victims
as a way to bring awareness i guess but
they dressing up as holocaust victims
like
like in a glamorous way uh
it's [ __ ] crazy and weird bro yeah
here check it out
she's pretty her eyes let's keep her i
want her body
what's your number
[Music]
wait yeah this one i don't get why this
one's here
this one for sure so it says name julia
age 19
cause of death this one looks like
[Music]
cause of death i was put in auschwitz
camp at 19
and my family we were forced to work
it was painful exhausting we were also
tortured
this tick tock really
[Laughter]
we were told it was because our religion
oh no she did a
fake yuda star
go to the shower my mom and i were
holding hands
i felt as though i know i oh this one's
awesome
how did you die why do you look like
that i died in a gas chamber in
auschwitz
i am so sorry is there like music
usually what's happening
i muted it i'm afraid we'll get blocked
by one of these [ __ ]
i'll give you a taste it's just it's
they're lip syncing anyway yeah but it's
kind of hard to get the full
you want me to do it i'll play it down
i'll give a [ __ ]
i was in home making a stew and the
nazis came and they broke down my door
i mean what are we doing here they
started kicking me and beating me out of
my home
they shoved us on a train with a bunch
of other people from my town is this
like
well i guess it's well-intentioned but
bizarre
yeah i mean definitely well-intentioned
but
jeez outfits right
right now that's come on dude all right
come on how is this
right that's [ __ ] up bro one trend i
would have never
thought would happen yo bro you want to
do the died in auschwitz tick tock
challenge
[Music]
oh my god there's so many of them you're
in heaven we're happy to have you here
i like how i stopped really doing
anything
yeah she's got soot all over her face i
mean she died
or by the way you show up in heaven like
with sit on your face what kind of
[ __ ] is that you gotta take a shower
but he's supposed to show up
immaculately
yes dear but don't worry you'll like it
here
how did you die why is she so stoked
i died in the holocaust oh i'm so sorry
would you mind telling me about it
not at all i was i was a young girl with
a jewish family
people are saying the education system
really failed us
i know we're it's a shame we're turning
to tick tock for our
if this shows up on your tick tock feed
that's your fault
yeah what do you want what do you watch
to get this recommended
we were told to wait in a line for bread
[Music]
challenge vibes totally
welcome to heaven i guess that's me
looks like she got a herpe though
i don't think that's part of the
challenge can you tell me your story
yeah i died in the hall so i died in the
holocaust
i love that yeah so i died in the
holocaust
that's what it says
you're in heaven don't worry oh
oh what uh oh what is it little boy
it's a girl i'm fine
yeah exactly exactly you can't let me
down with a tick tock is our home sound
by
zach zack zack zack zack jack
i can't hear you because the video was
like dampening everything through zoom
oh he couldn't hear you over the sound
zach zach we said
oh tick tock is our home
tick tock is my home exactly
proud member i died of starvation and
exhaustion
tick tock is not going anywhere right
oh my god dude you really couldn't even
like try to look he's prisoner
three four seven guard you'll be leaving
and five
why does it feel so weird i just can't
even understand
because well a dude like this doesn't
care about the [ __ ]
holocaust and look at his hair and he's
wearing like a nike
like button-up shirt
[Music]
let's check up here
[Music]
that's it what is going on
tick tock is just weird oh
what she like she went back in time
tick tock is my home how is the song
related what
guy's name is this is she
she put paper on her cuts
i guess at least they're trying to make
the holocaust
i give you a part of like a cool trend i
give props to everyone but this guy
making the hall that's something that's
never happened yeah i agree at least
they're
saying that it happened yeah there's
enough people out there to say it didn't
even happen
at least they're not saying it didn't
happen that's already big ups
yeah no i agree they're in the right
place but it's just a bizarre trend i
was just surprised by it
it's just for me it's like super funny
in israel
it's like i don't know you would never
think to see something like that but
anywhere i'm shocked by it
i mean i think in in germany
this shit's like illegal to even like
spring up
hi i was supposed to show him how to
ride a bike
dude you gotta if you can tired
bro if you're gonna do this whole
auschwitz thing though you gotta try a
little harder than this
oh yeah what does this guy even do i
mean this this shit's stupid
all right we had some other music
i told him it was a game of
hide-and-seek i can't handle this [ __ ]
dude if you are in auschwitz why is this
song the auschwitz i can't do it
tick tock is my home yeah any shame if
anything happened to tick tock wouldn't
it
sure go pee okay uh
this is vin diesel uh his face is in the
toilet and he goes
gross i'm fine how am i supposed to do
this interview look at this woman
you want to read some comments off thank
you to all the members i just want to
say
the members make this possible in a time
when our podcast is under attack by
nefarious forces
coronavirus our sponsors have never been
this minimal
and we but also we've never been so
motivated
to deliver more content of a higher
quality
um and so the membership really is a
huge uh
is a is a huge beautiful thing for us
and we're very very very grateful for
everyone that's becoming
really makes a difference and allows us
to just continue to make this content
the way that we want for you guys and
trust me when i say
four episodes a week
soon and then and the next one is going
to be
off the chain
we're going to add an episode on what is
it tuesday so we'll be posting
monday tuesday wednesday thursday
wait no no not wednesday
no we'll be posting monday tuesday
thursday friday sorry yeah
right something like that yeah it's
going to be awesome
uh there was a donation
that i wanted to read off uh this wasn't
it
uh 200 uh i'm sorry ayush i i do not
know what that symbol is
it looks like yen or something or i
can't really it's not yen though i don't
know what that is but anyways
uh you can get under 200 by so-called
dieting and exercising
but how are you planning to keep it off
forever well one step at a time
well no that's a good point i mean most
people most people that
lose weight ninety percent of them gain
it back within like two years
i mean it happens to you a lot you try
something and it works
but then you don't stick with it so no
it's it's really
i mean that's a good yeah it's tough oh
ab said that was two dollars whatever it
was okay
but thank you awesome that it looks like
it's so much
it's a rupee i believe indian rupee oh
indiana shout out to the uh
shout out man so and then a 50 one
please
get uh drew goodin on the show and
apologize for calling him drew goodman
on the logic
episode oh his name's not good man
what's his last name
good n oh well we have we have uh
i i am trying to get him on um i've
damned him and uh we're
hopefully we'll be able to set up a date
i mean i don't i don't
i shouldn't even say that because i
don't want people to like the guy has
the right to not want to come on he
didn't say he doesn't want to come on
i've just what i'm saying is that it's a
hole
i'm just kidding wait people were asking
if i washed my hands
yes i did why do you think i wouldn't ah
they're pretty dry dude
it was good crazy so um we have a lot
this is gonna be exciting because we
have a only fans
member who's going to call and add to
this story but
bella thorne the ex-disney
actress actor did you notice that all of
a sudden
um actresses are now actors
it's interesting i just all of a sudden
because i feel like it used to be
actress
yeah and now it's just actor when did
that happen
i don't know when it happened but it did
happen but
um like it makes sense why do you need
another word to describe a female
is it's pretty weird because in english
you don't really have male
female right you know like in hebrew
everything is male female
but but and and everything yeah it's
like firefighter police officer
it's not like police officers
yeah so actor i like let's get that
actress [ __ ] out of here
you know so bella thorne actor
who is always uh
she's one of these disney characters
who's like i mean she posts a lot of
risque
stuff and and people been i guess
probably asking for only fans for a
while
and so she made it
and she made a million dollars
in 24 hours really broke the record by
far
a million dollars oh my god and then
apparently she made over two million
dollars in the first few days alone
whoa so her tier levels
were it was twenty dollars just to get
in the door
wow so she had a couple of tears so z
who went in here we we actually
was it zach yeah it was me so tell me we
you we dropped the 20
what did you find inside well i had the
lotion ready
and i was very disappointed really you
couldn't even beat off to it
i'm kidding it was just very risque
photos and
um there was no nudity i mean was it
worth the 20 bucks i mean
no no did you cancel it
uh yeah i did zach what the [ __ ] bro
you better cancel that yeah very very
disappointing i'm calling the credit
card company i'd be like my son
did this i'd like to reverse the charges
yeah that wouldn't be the first time
yeah no
in fact i think they're get so there's
other tiers though there's another one
that was 200 that she reportedly told
people in a dm
or something here let's see i saw this
on twitter today do we have a picture of
this
she said full on straight up nudity
for the members who pay 200 dollars
jesus there's a where's this image did
you guys find this the image of her
yeah there's a message of her saying oh
the message because i think it's
it's important to show the
yeah when you guys can find that and
throw that in discord but
so the problem is
is that she's not delivering the nudes
and a lot of people are charging back
only fans and it's causing a lot of
problems for the platform and it's
affecting
other users of only fans
for example they recently
changed some of the terms of service as
a result of her
going on there i'm trying to find the
details here like it used to be that
um there was an unlimited level of tears
that you could charge
so now they lowered it to 50. oh
because they were everyone for everybody
and then they also maxed the tip amount
to a certain amount
for everybody because the platform was
getting absolutely
hammered by chargebacks because she
wasn't showing them titties
yeah here here it is thank you ian
here it is so uh
here someone said unlock for two hundred
dollars naked naked
yes naked how naked is the question for
two hundred dollars
no clothes naked
this is just a compilation of tweets and
stuff but it says bellathorne scammed
her fans and set out a 200
non-nude ppv is that why the max ppv
price is 50 now and why fans can only
tip 100
now because this dumb b word scammed
everyone
and only fans is getting massive amounts
of chargebacks
so somehow her
her doing this has like affected a lot
of these sex workers on the
platform so and then abe just put
a uh a tweet where she said also no
i'm not doing nudity so i mean was that
that screenshot was of a dm
i mean can't those be faked it could be
fake very very very certainly
everybody but so like i mean if she
didn't lie
can we blame her for because i saw a lot
of people were just mad in general that
she
did this because i guess they feel like
maybe the she's stepping on the toes of
sex workers
yeah there's a comment here saying she
made an only fans to find her movie
about her sex
work life but she was never a part of
that community to begin with
well she she made off two million dollar
i mean i surprised so many people paid
for that i mean
damn just to see some titties dude 20
bucks or not even to see some titties
so what kind did you see like what did
we see there did we see
through that wasn't at the end that it
went out to all her members oh so that's
real
that's according to people i mean that's
that then that's unquestionable
she just straight up lives yeah it's
just i actually think that's fraud yeah
we're talking about
titty frauds which is crazy to say but
that's fraud remember who was the uh ian
would remember there was like a rapper
or somebody that everybody got super mad
at for
for lying about releasing nudes
really yeah that was a doge academy
right oh yeah that one yeah right we
talked about that too this one's
different
different yeah right that i'm saying
like this one is actual fraud like she
just straight up lied
she's gonna get sued this is gonna be a
huge that's not a problem for her
so that we need to get can you guys get
to the truth of this um
yeah if this was a real message or fake
regarding yeah i mean it
i mean it's shitty either way what's
what's happening in the you know the
platform
clamping down but it makes a big
difference yeah it's a huge difference
she made that claim and then went back
on it
um so anyway we have and only fans
member who uh who is she ready to cute
to
to jump in i'd like to ask her about
this
as someone oh yeah let me check real
quick and what's her name what's what's
the
info about her you spoke with her zach
could you
sniff sniff is her name
who's sniffing hill right
good question i would call that uh
false advertising right see he knows
something about that it's not fraud
that's not true right so what is it
actually actually i feel like ja rule
and and bell
uh bella thorne would be really good
business partners
maybe they can put on a festival
together uh she's in the lobby
what's her name sniff sniff are you
there
yeah hi sniff why do we call it sniff
well actually my instagram name is sniff
you
so it's kind of embarrassing and
ridiculous but
my friends used to be bullying me
because i love to
like smell sweat i guess
oh so you you have a stench you have a
stink to you
no no i like to smell others sweat i
don't
oh you like to smell other people's
sweat
yeah does it uh does it is it a sexual
thing or you just like the smell i don't
know
actually i thought whenever my brothers
like smelled like sweat i thought that
it was perfume oh my gosh so i just
thought it was like really
it's pretty gross dude that's pretty
gross
but when you're with a guy do you like
to
partake in the smell or is it just not a
sexual thing
um well it could be you could yeah yeah
yeah fascinating i think there's a lot
of guys who put a cop probably i mean
that's kind of it
cool that you don't have to worry about
stinking in fact do you like
when you're with a guy do you like him
to not shower or too much
yeah so what's a good amount of time to
to not
shower for your boyfriend that depends
on the guy
but i like the smell so
and so and so like are we talking maybe
not everyday shower clear maybe like
once a week
well i like them to be clean i just like
the smell
so it's kind of like a difficult
situation so maybe they would shower but
just not wash the the armpits at all
ever
yes wow interesting would you like me to
try that
[Music]
man sniff you interesting
you ever smell people out in public when
you're like maybe because i'm thinking
like
yeah on the train or whatever when
you're in close proximity you can catch
a whiff of bo
most people would be like oh man that's
crazy but maybe you lean in a little
closer and
see what's up it's like how you feel
when you smell
glue kind of how some people feel when
they smell glue like it
it's like oh my god that's great wow
that's awesome that's really cool
like until now that's been a secret so
do you like your own smell
no actually i never smelled my own sweat
until like two weeks ago maybe and it
was horrible
yeah that's interesting because usually
we like our own smells
and not the other way around so a
fascinating case study
uh sniff do you have any opinion about
feet
um i personally i don't like
feet necessarily but i can totally see
why
people would like it i have a lot of
people asking me for feeds
pictures absolutely
now let me ask you this is it
particularly the armpit smell you like
or
because sometimes like the pubic area
can get super wild
do you like that smell as well um
it's it's a difficult situation because
i like it but it's
sometimes it can be like smell like
death
oh my goodness that does sound like a
that certainly does sound tough
do you ever just put your nose in
someone's armpit or pubes and just
like right in there and just breathe
deep
yes that's awesome i do that's awesome
and do is there other is do different
people have better smells or is it all
good
i actually have smelled very few people
i used to do cheerleading and i would
smell a lot of
stuff for them um but
girl sweat is a little bit different i
think
thank god would you ever sneak smells of
like dirty underwear and stuff
no what about like a shirt would you
ever sneak like
you find a shirt on the ground you go
and sniff it
yeah yeah yeah god i love you
yeah vin diesel's a fan and you're not
from the us
right where are you from no i'm from
norway
oh cool that's awesome dude let me ask
you this
if you're are you in a committed
relationship or have you ever been
uh yes i've been in a few but i'm not
very experienced in like the
relationship
area can i ask you in a particular
situation let's say you're dating a guy
would it be let's say uh
would it be considered an act of
cheating
to go sniff another person's
you know discarded clothing for example
um i'm not sure about that actually i
don't think he would be cheating maybe
like a little fuss yeah it would be i
would feel maybe a little insecure if i
was like damn she's out there sniffing
other dudes armpits and [ __ ]
and yeah you know what i mean like it
might make me feel a little insecure is
all i'm
yeah saying probably wouldn't say that i
would do it but maybe if i
like went by a
guy's wardrobe or something yeah i would
do it secretly
yeah i i have a feeling that uh this is
a passion of yours that probably
you think you'll be sniffing arpes till
the day you die or maybe like once you
hit menopause you'll get over the
smelling
i have donated since i was little i
think it's something that's like
integrated into me so i'll probably be
doing it forever
that's awesome well let me ask you let's
move on to the only fans
uh controversy do you have any thoughts
on the bella
thorne issue
yeah um i really honestly think it sucks
that
that even happened and i
definitely think that the fact that she
did that she should be held accountable
because it's not okay to false advertise
you shouldn't like be clear on what
you're selling
and what you're doing and not why did we
um
sounds like she was unclear from what a
b said
yeah i was trying to find out did she
really say there was new nudes or
or because we're kind of confused on
this
on twitter it just seemed like she just
announced it
oh she just tweeted that there's no
nudes
but like on the actual announcement of i
guess the only offense she wasn't clear
um correct well i think it's fair to
assume that there will be nudes on
bullying fans right i mean i mean well i
guess i would assume that but
i always thought that too but evidently
not got a plug some of it's just uh
risque stuff so what do you do on only
fans do you do
to what extent do you go well i don't do
completely new content and i can see why
it would seem like that because of the
website and like the whole
expectation of things but i actually
have very few
people who subscribe to me that are like
disappointed
um that roaring news because
often people will subscribe for like
custom content or
i do like a lot of i don't know how to
say it but i hate
guru or whatever the anime hentai face
do you watch hentai when you get off
i used to but now i am in like the
i don't watch anything at all oh you
gave it up
because i've actually been interested to
talk to somebody who likes hentai
because
like as much as i i like
i've heard people say of hentai they
know that nobody there's no victim in
that so
i i think that's a really good i think
that's good right
but it but i just it doesn't do anything
for me the hentai
so um i guess i just wonder what they
like about it yeah i guess it just
it's good i mean do you like hentai
better than normal porn
i when i used to watch porn i
stopped because it really depressed me
but when i used to do it
um i would watch hentai because of the
fact that like
it's so brutal kind of and you can watch
girls like get
tons of tentacles and stuff you can like
monsters and everything stuff you can't
watch in normal porn
so that's why i watched it at least oh
so you were you liked how brutal the
hentai was
yeah so oh that's fascinating so tell me
about it we don't want to see like a
brutal
actual porn so that's why like well
sometimes they role play really hardcore
stuff but maybe it's depressing because
it's a real person right
that's what you're saying no like i
would watch it as long as it's
consensual
but the thing is that it doesn't
like the normal porn they don't do all
the stuff that you can animate
oh it's nice yeah they don't do all the
tentacles and monsters and everything
that i was into
oh that's so interesting so what is it
about the tentacles and monsters that
that you like i've always been curious
about that
i'm not sure i think it's just the fact
that
the other person is like are helpless
i it's a lot guess
like um yeah brutal intense and
everything
so you you do you so you like to see it
on maybe the
the rougher more brutal side and the
the tentacles deliver that that promise
where the uh people
sometimes fail yeah because the
tentacles you know they're slimy they
can be big or small and they can go
everywhere and sometimes
how are you ever gonna how can you ever
be pleased by a man when when you're
competing with tentacles
well i i when i used to watch it
i hadn't had actual sex yet oh you're
virgin
no no not anymore but when i used to
and now i realized that you know i don't
really watch it anymore so
it's fine just having normal sex like i
don't need it
i find it absolutely fascinating that
what before you ever had sex it was the
tentacle part
do you ever fantasize about what
tentacles smell like
no i don't i'm just curious you never
know where
so you like all kinds of what smells oh
smells yeah
for sure what about the smell of semen
i've always found that really disgusting
but maybe you like it
i don't like i never
get to smell it before it's gone right
would you maybe like would you maybe
like your partner to set it aside for a
little bit so you can smell it
i actually asked my partner once to
if i could collective human in a cup
right and put it in resin so that i had
like a cup of semen in wrestling like on
display
you wanted to you wanted to you wanted
to put it in what
on this lesson inside them you can make
like uh
like what belt usb of nodes for us
oh you wanted to you wanted to preserve
his semen yeah
interesting for future generations
was it like an art project or i got to
tell you dude
i mean that's that's really that's
really cool
um well i think that you know i think
it's a shame that
that bell came in and if she if she or
bella if she really lied about the nudes
then
it sucks because as i understand it
she's limited the amount of money
you guys can make now in terms of tips
and tier levels is that right
yeah well on only fans there aren't
really
tears per se but
you can like tip and then you can get
into like a special
thing i guess um but yeah it really
sucks that like
she's ruining it she's like trying to
empower the sex workers but she's like
ruining it
for the sex workers and it sucks
but only fans has had a lot of
controversy like in general recently
really about what um well apparently
i haven't really updated in a few days
but apparently
they have like um they're getting sued
because they're not paying taxes
oh what the heck yeah i don't know if
that's like
how true that is but
that's what i read everywhere and
they're like apparently deleting
content creators but don't quote me on
that
but i've been thinking of like moving
over to patreon or something
only fans steeped in controversy well it
opens uh faces allegations of fraud
and theft you know that's august 13th
come on man get you get it together well
i hope that whatever happens
i mean they got to get it together i
mean i'm sure you're paying taxes right
uh sniff
you know why can't they yeah yeah yeah i
actually had to make a whole business
just to pay taxes in our way
yeah well sniff i've really enjoyed
talking to you and learning about you
thank you for sharing with us
what is your only fans i'm sure there's
a lot of people with a box of tissue
and moisturizer that wouldn't mind going
over your page what is your page
um well my instagram is just
nephew sniff um yeah sniff you
just straight up and they're my only
fancy in the link there
so everything is linked and my own fans
is just my view too
well keep on sniffing i think it sounds
fantastic and um
tell me sniff can i ask you something
what was like the most nin
the riskiest sniff you ever took
uh probably when i was cheerleading
like just like um smithing people when i
caught
them like in my arms or whatever they
probably heard me because they were
right there so whoa so you would just
put your you know
like loud like and go like a real deep
smell
although people i mean people are
probably they did
are for because i don't sniff his armpit
though
no um
although i probably imagine the reaction
is a lot less severe if it was just a
dude that looked like me
you know
[Music]
yeah probably well does anyone does
anyone ever get mad at you
if they catch you sniffing them that
that hasn't happened but that's never
happened
wow that's boyfriend think that it's
weird
let me ask you this sniff how do you
wipe
i just i i wipe front to back
and then when i'm done when there's
nothing left i
shower with um soap oh you shower every
time you poop
no but i make sure to shower every day
like
at the end of the wash wow so you're
just a regular wiper yeah no things no
surprises
do you look do you look like i don't
work or anything
you don't you don't finger yourself do
you look at
the wipes every time or is it just yeah
you do
every time every time i used to use a
lot of baby wipes but
after you guys told me about everything
i stopped
you should get uh you should i really
recommend like you can get a bidet
connector
that aren't expensive i mean tushy has
one that's like 65 bucks it's really
good so
i recommend that but anyway sniff it's
been a joy and a pleasure i've learned
a lot and i'm and i'm absolutely
fascinated so thank you for sharing
interesting yeah
but listen one second yes i just want to
say something really quick to
like the people who are watching because
you were talking about your
body and body issues earlier and i just
wanted to say that
all the chubby guards out there like
it's okay
i feel like there aren't enough focus on
body positivity for men
and i just want to say there are girls
out there who will love you and you are
beautiful as you are
or guys if you're into guys i just
wanted to say that
are you a chubby chaser i don't like
like a little extra schmidt i do
really so she she likes
meat i think that's what she said so are
you
are you attracted more to like a guy of
my size
than a skinny dude yeah
um there you go i mean
i'm not very attracted to like a skinny
dude not
skinny but like yeah but i couldn't
understand why you are like well
yeah but that's interesting dude
everyone in the chat is like dude this
girl is
perfect she likes this she likes
stinks she likes the fat dude i mean
hello
so do you like a dude generally dudes
who are hairier probably smell more is
that you look for a hairy guy
yeah damn look at this
are you currently looking for uh are you
currently looking for love
um i'm not really i'm very focused on
the business and university but i'm open
for boyfriend applications
are you interested in possibly being on
the next season of the bachelor
oh yes that'd be awesome and that would
know
now that would be interesting it does
always end in a disastrous way though so
well but so far but you know a lot
that's perfect yeah
it's a roller coaster all right thank
you sniff take care all right
thanks for calling all right bye
wow dude these calls are great so is
are you guys hearing sound bites through
the call because we aren't
uh we are i think but uh part of the
problem is zach uh
because we're doing the calls through
discord he's not hearing it on zoom
got it so he's not able to like live
react to it i'll try and figure out
maybe there's a way we can
figure that out for the next episode so
that he can listen in on the call yeah
abby says he can't but i gotta say
so what we've been doing is pre-vetting
people on discord
and and it's working great because the
calls today have been fan-fucking-tastic
yeah this was amazing
i loved listening i love how open she
wasn't actually talking to people
just you know random listeners dude she
loves she sniffs people on the train
deeply but that's kind of like pretty
girl privilege right
she can go up to people and go if i did
that i'd get i would be in jail already
that's true and she says no one's ever
got mad at her
yeah i'd probably just be more confused
that's true i would be very well she's
the thing is she's really like a small
sweet petite girl so she's not very
threatening yeah
maybe maybe that's what dude on the
floor was doing when he was spying
you're trying to get a sniff in there my
favorite guy who goes why are you on the
floor
wow that was awesome so did we ever get
a final verdict on what was the truth
behind bella thorne's only fans
um it just sounds like she was not clear
but what is that screenshot of her
telling them
yes fully new two hundred dollars well
the chat said that that was on
her only fans that wasn't a dm that was
so that's what's up
we don't have like a hard proof but yeah
i mean
people can fake screenshots and stuff so
i mean
let me lock and see if it's on there
hold on i mean it's pretty
she probably removed it pretty weird to
be not clear
to from the beginning also it's so
expensive you would
you know i would expect to see at least
a butthole for 20 bucks
200 yeah it's a lot 200 yeah well for
200 i better see a [ __ ]
somebody wiping with a swirl and a dip
okay this next segment you guys
we may lose all of our viewers because
it's so
[ __ ] disgusting oh god is this the
popping
it's so we gotta go we gotta give a big
heads up because i think
some people some people probably can't
hang with this
i'm saying i think we're going to lose
all of our viewers i think it's going to
drop
out uh let's take a
we're at about 17 000 right now
and i so i'll just give a background
there's this whole phenomenon lately of
pimple popping
something frankly that has always
horrified me
now i know that there's certain people
that really like it for whatever reason
for example i had friends in college
that would
want me they would ask people in general
take off your shirt and let me pop your
pimples
that to me is just like as gross as it
gets
yeah yet here we are for example there's
that toy
that we did with the dumb products where
you pop the pimples there's a show now
on tlc called dr pimple popper which by
the way
is a crime against god himself i hate
when they even just show a commercial
for it
i feel like the commercial is too
graphic yeah
you know sometimes i'm on instagram
because i'm all about that instagram
discovery feed that's how i found like
the turkish chefs and all these people i
love
and sometimes they'll give the hero slot
this huge
square as just a really graphic popping
video
and i'm like you cannot
just throw that on me like that nope
and i get really upset so i don't know
how many so but
i guess it's going to be entertaining to
watch me be forced to watch this i think
that's what's entertaining
because i will tell you i am truly and
honestly
horrified and disgusted max level
there's not much that disgusts me i saw
a dude
uh eating a toe deep throating a foot
and i made me want to eat subway that's
a good point
i just realized though this really is
all about the reaction
and um the way everything's structured
right now is uh
i don't have like the picture in picture
where we can see you guys while the
video is playing
oh it's okay you know well you can just
face well you can just cut back and
forth
yeah i mean what can you do i can add
one real quick dude
i honestly am so i so don't want to
watch this but i'm going to do it for
the show this is what h3 after dark is
all about
wait give me one second i can i can set
this up can can one of you guys get
someone on the call
closer to me yeah yeah i can grab
someone quick i want someone who
who who's into this oh yeah someone here
said their wife loves it
yeah i dude i swear to god it's female
it's females that love this
i've never met a dude i hate it
[Music]
you can never i've never known a dude
who likes this but it's
all females i don't know if it's like
it's like these monkeys that [ __ ]
you know you see these monkeys like no
they don't
what monkeys are they're always grooming
each other oh growing each other
yeah it's it's like an act of grooming i
think is is what it is
that one all right i set it up i've got
a little i got a little boxing box here
for you oh that was nice
very slick then well let's just watch it
i've warned you guys
i'm curious to see if our viewers go
down it went down a little bit not as
much as i'd expect though
but everybody's checking dude don't do
it this is all dude what the [ __ ] i
didn't even show this is so
[ __ ] up i mean this is on facebook
i mean traumatized you gave birth you
had a baby come
spiraling out of your vagina bro you
know what i can't do it
you have to it's for the show
so this one's popping back and popping
back spot with muscles
and do it what
i did i didn't look
oh that was nothing there was nothing
yeah that one is really cold on the
stream
dude why would anybody even film this
no
there was like an after birth did you
see the second one
that doesn't seem normal that doesn't
seem what is wrong that's not a pimple
that's like a [ __ ] tumor
it's gonna traumatize me look
you you
never even seen a pimple that big
exactly
this is like the most tame one of those
it is
i can't i think this is it i don't think
i can go on
wait it's a cyst you're not supposed to
i don't think you're supposed to pop
assist like that well you know
well they're supposed to do it
professionally is the thing dude
they're all on facebook facebook doesn't
give a [ __ ] as well man
it's a wild west on there imagine this
is on your feet in facebook i see people
in the chat though saying
wow that's so satisfying like some
people find it
that's the thing extremely satisfying i
find it like
as [ __ ] gross as it gets
let's not what look how big that is
careful
you have to watch somebody's face i'm
telling you it's probably alright
my face so we're pretty gold in there no
how big is that ah squirted in her face
see you're just do you mean lighting the
top surface stuff
do you need lidocaine do you want to
inject him
she asks if he needs an injection of
painkiller why is it so big
you don't get a say in this sir
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay are we done i know i don't
[Applause]
[Applause]
watch this you have to see this no i
don't know you have to watch it it hit
the camera
holy [ __ ]
oh my god okay so there's people that
aren't absolutely horrified by that and
find it like satisfying we're not
watching it anymore that's it
oh we did lose did we lose no we didn't
was about 100 people really not that
much
how can you enjoy that here's enough we
have to do this for the show this is the
whole point how many more this dude's on
his [ __ ]
face what the [ __ ] dude this is the
whole wait hold on i'm more interested
what is this facebook page they've got
like the whole soflow [ __ ]
it's called this facebook page is called
spot popping
satisfication satisfies
satisfaction
[Laughter]
so the the description is this is so
satisfying but i can feel his pain
there's no way i i can't believe wait is
that real
is that real look how big it is how can
that be real i feel like that's gotta be
fake
it looks real though it's really like
the how do you just
why how do you wait that long to address
that no
this one's going to be so bad it's going
to be so
bad why is he smiling
how does he let it go people are begging
no
and i am begging oh
there she was
[Music]
disgusting
[Applause]
[Music]
clean it up please
[Music]
how can there be so much
you have there's one way worse than this
coming up if we keep going he smelled it
oh come on
doesn't smell very good either how does
he let it go that far that first of all
that is just
that's so [ __ ] wrong how do you let a
pimple get that big on your [ __ ] face
to begin that's what makes me think it's
fake
what do you mean let i mean it just
happens
how long does it take to get a pimple
that big i've never seen a pit bull that
big
ever anywhere in the world well yeah
i i can't get it really i can't explain
exactly
it happens
that's why i said it's traumatizing me
because i think it's gonna happen then
man has mayo dispenser on his shoulder
you [ __ ] seriously gonna title it
that
just for dan okay i i don't know about
you oh this guy looks like a legend
that guy looks like michael moore
cut it here oh my gosh ela's saying bail
i'm kind of with her i gotta agree on it
too yeah
no we're committed god really we didn't
lose that many viewers i'm just saying
i'm just saying we only lost 100 i was
expecting
yeah do you still want a subway
no no i don't know so maybe i'm still
maybe this could be a good diet just
okay i'm just going to watch one more
you guys tell me which is the one i
should watch
biggest cyst of all time big assists of
all time pop
warning disgusting so it's a cyst it's
not even a pimple at this point
yeah i mean they yeah they kind of
overlap it's just like a really big
pimple
so let's get rid of this michael moore
how is he managed
um i guess i didn't realize that
okay so so this is oh dude i cannot
[ __ ] wait what am i looking at it
looks like her hand is enjoying
this no you see that i can't wait a
million
dude a million people watch this villa
that's gonna happen to me you know
a million people watch this
let me read the comments before i get
into this more than likely that'll grow
back because the sack wasn't removed
learned a lot from that
from the dr pimple popper imagine being
in a family reunion
then someone suggests to pop grandpa's
back cyst
i think the gagging noises were worse
than the actual video
that dude sounds like you ethan in the
video yeah actually
every thanksgiving we milk uncle larry
in the backyard
okay we have to we have to watch it
makes it even worse
okay i don't want to click it
i feel like before i feel like before
you're about to do something like
intensely painful
you know like it's like that dreading
i'm that dreading
makes your skin crawl yeah why
where is it like on the body
yeah dude you've got to see a doctor you
need to see a doctor
don't let dude this should not be taking
place in a backyard
exactly it looks like cheese it looks
like cottage cheese
it's like curded
no don't laugh you need to go to a
doctor
it's coming out like cottage cheese i
swear to god
it looks
dude go to a doctor please go to a
doctor this is not the setting
imagine the dog comes and eats that it's
on the grass
oh my [ __ ] god oh my [ __ ] god
cool
[Laughter]
wait there's still that much time
there's nothing oh yeah
but i mean we got the idea right
you almost puke right there anything
does anyone ever watch dr pimple popper
while they eat
well i'm just wondering like how does
that show have any view view ratings
it must have
have you seen them numbers online
they're crazy
no what do you mean by that dr pimple
popper she started online if i'm not
mistaken oh like her youtube videos
instagram and then youtube eventually
and then she got her show
oh so she's just a passionate pimple
popper that
that found success on tlc
somebody i've got someone who called in
who who
is into this type of stuff okay
especially dr pimple popper
name though uh karen karen oh no
uh karen are you with us uh she's in now
karen oh hey first of all
how how what's going on with you being
named karen how's that affected your
life since the karen meme has
come about okay so um it's
i i feel like i have the title of i'm
the only
person who can legitimately be offended
by being called karen
because um i'm trans and that's my dead
name
so oh wait it's your wife it's your
wait i'm sorry i just it's your dead
name yeah
yeah so it's like the name i was giving
at birth
okay so you're so you're you're a male
really
um i'm not binary but yeah oh but so do
you want us to call you karen yeah
what's your name
um i go by ren so why did he did ian
why did ian introduce you as karen well
because i just
i mentioned to him that that's my legal
name i didn't tell him that
okay so we'll call you wren yeah
yeah so karen so that's kind of you yeah
i mean on many levels
[Laughter]
yeah so it's kind of good you you bailed
on that name
yeah yeah i mean what's funny is that
the
meme didn't bother me until the boomers
caught
wind of it um and then
they wanted to keep having conversations
and like complain to me about it as if i
would be like sympathetic towards them
oh they are looking to you for like
oh that's interesting yeah so really
like oh you hate this meme too
let me complain to you about it oh my
god i wonder if there's facebook groups
for karen's
who are like coping with the more
let me ask you what the [ __ ] is wrong
with you
why do you watch this [ __ ] tell me what
you
feel when you watch this what's wrong
with me is i have ocd
um and so i have um
sort of a sub condition that's related
to ocd called dermatillomania
um which is basically like compulsive
skin picking
um and so i will just like
absolutely demolish my skin um
and like it started with just acne but
then it
very quickly turned into like any
visible
pores or body hair or just like
anything on my skin that wasn't just
like perfectly like smooth and flat and
um you know not discolored um and so i
kind of use these videos as a way to
like um
keep myself from doing that to sort of
satisfy like that obsession without
destroying myself does it help you
that's so interesting
yeah um it's sort of um
yeah i find it kind of satisfying
because the way i sort of explain
this obsession because i know it sounds
kind of weird um is
that like my brain interprets any like
acne or anything like that
kind of like it's um a parasite or
something
like there's this awful um like
bad thing under my skin that is trapped
under there and i need to like remove it
by whatever means necessary
and so it's sort of feeling like i need
to get it out of my body and so
um those videos were i i'm not a big fan
of the cysts
um i don't find them really gross but um
the fact that like you have to like keep
going and keep going and it doesn't come
out in like one satisfying bit
it's kind of um not as good for me
i guess so i can imagine that
it's probably quite damaging to your to
your body
if you're constantly picking pores and
hairs and stuff
yeah um i don't wear tank tops in public
anymore because of it because like
i mostly focus on my shoulders and my
chest um
and it has just like gotten to the point
where like
it i just constantly have these
like they're the size of like maybe a
pencil eraser
but they're just like um all over my
shoulders and
just lots of scars and such yeah so what
are you
are you in therapy are you taking some
kind of medicine to help
the lower the urges
i mean i tried therapy but um i think
i haven't found the right one yet yeah
um i
i went to um a psychiatrist for it
um but this psychiatrist absolutely
sucks she was like oh you should stop
doing that
i'm like that's all that she said it's
not quite
like okay sure i'm curious i wish
someone said that i'm cured
well it's actually well for you in your
case i'm very glad that you're able to
find this kind of content that uh if
it's helpful to you then that's
fantastic do you feel that you do it
less when you watch those videos
i mean i think so hmm
yeah but do you ever pick while you're
watching
um no i don't usually
um i sometimes wonder if it might
trigger me to start doing it so i don't
know if i'm like
if i should stop entirely or if like if
it's really helping me or if it's just
like feeding into it
but well probably a good therapist could
help you figure that out
that's tough though yeah well wren
thank you for sharing yeah and i wish
you all the best with uh
with getting that under control i hope
you hope you
up you get it yeah
thanks for calling me in this is fun all
right thank you
yeah this was really interesting god
bless thank you
so it does so everybody who watches the
show
has uh ocd or probably not everybody but
okay
but no but that is an interesting angle
i i think there is a connection there
a b found uh dr pimple popper's uh views
and put a screenshot of him in discord
you gotta see this okay this is her
youtube channel or like her let's see
i think her youtube yeah
so this okay so she was like a
phenomenon before she got her own tlc
show whoa dude no [ __ ] way what
62 million yeah 49 million 40
i guess i should watch these what
are you seeing that on his next
grapefruit one oh which one
yeah the middle the middle right now oh
wow
see how can you put this in a thumbnail
this to me seems obscene and and
horrific
i guess because it's done i mean it's me
although these are all super old i bet
youtube doesn't allow this [ __ ] to get
like suggested anymore
here let me look at it i gotta they got
a tv show now so yeah she's out
she looks like you youtube dr pimple
popper youtube
dr sandra lee what's the difference zach
oh that's heard
i mean her real name is dr sanderly oh
oh but that's her channel because what
did i just see is this
her this is her channel oh she's dude
she's got almost
7 million subscribers wow it's so big
the whole genre dude she's banking on
this [ __ ]
imagine this like she's got a passion
she's got
she's got fans so this is number one i
mean we have to watch it
really yeah 62 million people watch
this one that walks up on us dude sixth
away dude
62 million people watch this this is
this is
apparently something incredible like a
black hole like
like the two black so it's an 85 year
old woman
a giant blackhead it is a giant
blackhead extracted in an 85 year old
woman
oh boy this is dude you have to
appreciate the fact that 62 million
people have watched this
like you have to we have to contribute
okay you're the one that can't get up
and walk away
i i might okay enough with the
[ __ ] preamble that looks
so bad she's got all these disclaimers
and [ __ ] i'm surprised so many people
oh they're actually um oh they give her
painkillers
well at least she's a doctor you know
what i mean
it's not like it's not like uh
kerning cheese in the backyard what
about our pain
what's the injection for that you had a
baby
i still can't watch that i watched the
baby come out that was pretty wild
yeah that was pretty wild you didn't
have to watch it you had to do it but
you didn't have to watch it
yeah you have to watch this too many
people have watched this video first not
to watch it yes i can see it oh you can
see in the mirror okay you see it in the
mirror
yeah man this is some [ __ ]
i feel like why everyone's typing f does
that mean
don't watch it i'm watching it i can't
not i mean there's too many views
there's lots of well look i mean
i i warned you guys okay i'm gonna put a
little number here so
don't move on too much here because i
don't wanna have it hurt yeah
can you put novocaine into my emotions
i'm just gonna numb around it so that
you can't feel me kind of this thing
stop right here
because the last you said it keeps
coming out joining a long time
60 million you guys 60 million people
watch this don't be such [ __ ]
it wasn't deep she said twice
twice 60 million
that you can just not feel anything
that's so cool
she's really pumping her full holy
[ __ ]
wait that's like a lot of [ __ ]
novocain
yeah and says oh core
60 million isn't she supposed to let the
nova king kick in for a minute it's
pretty fast
okay is everybody ready no
we lost a lot of viewers did you already
get it no
i didn't i didn't we're losing viewers
interrupting you i'm sorry
we're always ignoring you i can't listen
to
you
we're watching like a disgusting surgery
this isn't even like those black pants
oh my god that wasn't that bad that
actually wasn't that bad
that's insane look no no no it wasn't as
bad as the other ones it's actually
super interesting
yeah whoa
look
the other [ __ ] was way more disgusting
that was like yeah i would say the uh
that caught his shoes
see i think it was done like medically i
can see how this was satisfying because
it like all came out in one pole and it
was just a big
crater this one is those other ones were
just
horrific but i mean this is horrific but
okay
not as
[Laughter]
you're just giving me the help
yeah actually it's uh 2 30 and uh we got
the
the thing that we can't mention yet
oh is that we have something um
is there anything else not really we did
it all there
is there any other calls anyone other
comments any uh donations
we're gonna end the show we have uh one
guy who's been in the call lobby with
his
essay okay oh let's talk to him all
right i got
awesome nerd is his name let me drop it
in the server really quick if you guys
want to look at some donations
oh uh sure uh we have yes what is
uh do more blackhead popping uh i don't
think that's gonna happen sorry uh
uh smarsh i'm sorry i'm if i'm saying
your name wrong
um but yeah i can't believe how that he
was over it and
what he says goes so uh hey ethan uh all
gas no brakes just released some video
from the sturgis motorcycle rally
on insta go check it out uh no way
definitely check that out
awesome oh dude i'm hanging out with him
today
wait what yeah he's coming over what
yeah he moved to l.a he's coming to hang
out
no way texting me tonight oh [ __ ]
cool uh well
very cool uh what is this five dollar
donation
is just a crying face i'm assuming
that's because of uh
because of these disgusting videos and
uh
i saw some earlier but i hate that they
expire i
maybe there's another way to see it but
uh i don't know if i missed your
donation i'm very sorry
i've been trying to keep up i'm still
i'm repeating that blackhead in my mind
it's just that's
stuck on a loop they're afraid because
that's crazy man that's crazy anyway do
we have this guy uh
avery you guys said the key to keeping
weight off after losing it
is a healthy personal relationship with
food
no other way okay
can i tell you something either that i
have a kind of a peeve to pick with you
oh jesus oh no okay i didn't say let
me say no it's not let me say something
yeah i i i say
i say sometimes i say because there's a
lot of snacks and sweets and [ __ ] in
the house
and as much as i'd like to be able to
control myself it's hard to sometimes
when you just see it in the pantry or
all over the place to skip but but hold
on
but you say you you always say to me
ethan
it's not my thing you have to control
your urges but ila would you say that to
an addict
let's say i was like i'm quitting
drinking would you believe alcohol say
it's your problem no
i disagree because i need that stuff
because but it's somewhere else is all
i'm saying don't put it in front of me
hide it
where it's in a pantry but if i have an
addiction to food
or then like just think about it if
you're like hey i like having a beer uh
don't go in the pantry then why do you
want me to hide it
i don't know but you understand what i'm
saying like you wouldn't say that to an
addict like
dude you just got to control your urges
yeah you know it's not my fault i'm
going to drink a beer every night
so you're a food addict is what you're
asserting i think so yeah well i mean
i mean maybe you need to go to therapy
yeah rather than but even if you're a
recovering alcoholic you're not going to
leave
alcohol over the house because it's
triggering i've i feel like i've tried
it but like it's been so long
i know i'm not stuffing my i'm just i'm
not telling you not to eat it
i'm trying to gain weight too and that
stuff helps me i'm not
telling you not to eat it but what are
you telling me to have i don't know but
i'm just saying like
you're gonna find it you can't just
blame the the person with the addiction
saying like you have to be stronger than
like you know what i'm saying
i mean you there's so much [ __ ] and
candy in there it's impossible
like i haven't eaten not that much
you're making it sound like i have
so much dude there's a guy's closet's
shaming i'm not victim shaming you're
like hey dude
i like shooting up crap i like to smoke
crack it's not my fault you have a
problem
that's not what i said i am
acknowledging that i also have a problem
and i'm trying to
gain food but you don't have to gain but
just fair okay
stuff helps me gain weight okay fine but
i'm just saying it's not it's not cool
to be like dude it's your responsibility
to not eat this [ __ ] ever even though
you walk past it 20 times a day we
should meet in the middle
what do you want to do on your side like
let okay
maybe you just put it somewhere else
where i don't know there's a billion
places
you gotta hide it from him like uh well
okay i'm just saying i think it's
interesting that like
someone who's trying to lose weight
doesn't get that benefit of the doubt
i don't know it's like dude you have to
control yourself
but they say i was reading they're like
don't and leave snacks all over the
house because you're gonna [ __ ] eat
them
and i was like yeah you know and and if
i was living by myself i wouldn't buy
that [ __ ]
all right i'll put it in a secret drawer
people
love pizza and people yeah but why are
you making me feel guilty that's the
thing
because if again if i was an alcoholic
you wouldn't be like dude well i'm gonna
keep my beer in the fridge where i
always the first time that you're
putting it this way
if you feel like that just like dan said
let's also talk about therapy
and second of all i just feel like i've
tried that we've had no snacks in the
house and it's not good for me
but it's been so long that you're like
that like it's not like you're asking me
for a month let's not have anything in
the house like
you're just asking me do not have
anything tasty my
my observation was only about how
the fat people don't get the benefit of
the doubt
as a drug addict and i think fat people
matter
fat people lives matter all right
do you find do you think what i'm
observing is interesting or no you're
asking me
that's a question for everybody yeah who
are you well i mean it
i mean if you at first i wasn't sure if
you were just memeing but if you really
do feel like you're a food addict i mean
that's
uh you know well i feel like all fat
people are probably
food addicted i guess to an extent i
mean
you do really you live an extremely uh
sedentary life too i mean
if you if you did get the trainer and
you started working out you could
probably
well i don't know they probably tell you
you need to cut back on calories too but
it's the combination all right get the
guy in the call wait wait let me ask you
are
are you a stress eater like do you binge
eat
um sometimes not it's not like it's not
something that happens a lot but
benji i mean i don't i don't i don't
think that really happens
where i just like binge or i'm like
oh man don't look at me i don't know
he was mad i am don't you think that's
an interesting observation
i think you're not seeing the two sides
i know i see your side
my objective it's not even look i'm not
even trying to attack i'm not trying to
attack you i'm just saying
fat people don't get that like you would
never say to a drug addict
hey listen you just gotta control your
urges right
that's all i'm saying so i wonder
okay right i just think that's it do you
think that's interesting
exactly you also yeah is it interesting
no let me talk you also don't expect a
drug addict
to just get over it in one day right you
go to rehab
you do all kinds of stuff to try to get
out of it so
if you want to really treat it that way
then let's treat it that way
it's just an observation ela well
is it or are you just like
what i mean it sounds like you really
think that which i'm not saying it's
just not true yeah no i mean
yeah i do think that i mean a little bit
i just thought it was interesting though
that's all you're like backtracking now
well i'm not i'm not necessarily saying
i'm not necessarily saying that i need
to do 12 steps of not being a fatty
what is it called 12 steps yeah 12 steps
okay i don't know what you're saying
yeah
all right pizza is actually very
nutritious what does that mean because
zach actually lost a lot of weight
in his life well i i am a stress eater
that's why i ask that question and i
also
occasionally binge eat which is a
problem for me
so i'm always gonna have to be watching
my weight the rest of my life
how did you manage to keep the
like lose weight and then keep it that
way well
my problem is i fluctuate a yo-yo you're
a yo-yo
i'm a yo-yo um so i just
have to monitor it because i know that
the fat gene runs in my family
and that i was heavy and i don't want to
go back to that
place again and i keep thinking all the
hardship i went through so that always
is a good
thing to keep me motivated
let's keep zach beautiful or then even i
mean beauty is obviously
not related to how fat you are right
sure in most people's eyes it is
okay boring yeah and again uh we're
kind of coming up against it i don't
know if we have time for this other call
i'll probably wrap it up and keemstar is
going to say we have marital
marital problems now
so wait did we want to talk to this guy
where is he
you want me to bring him in yeah okay do
we not have time
right now we don't really have time yeah
we're going to keep it brief
and everything what's the wrap bring him
in bring him in
he's in he's in right now hey i'm i'm
here i'm i'm the guy
i'm sorry for all the spam okay avery
um yeah for christmas sir that's right
so avery's written a
essay why he makes thinks he'd make a
great caller
without reading this avery first give me
your most compelling point about why
you'd make a great caller
i think the reason why i'm most
compelling is because
just my existence it's so weird people
don't think i'm a real person
i'm a 6-8 black dude with a size 18
shoes my last name is a holiday
thanks to slavery i got a grower dick i
keep it wholesome
and i got these crazy like bomb ass
stories from just
you know being 26 years old so yeah i
i like people really wanted me on and
like i've always been a huge fan
from like your guys's growth from when
you guys did the
patrice stuff and like the papa john's
like before you got big from prank and
it's just been an honor watching you
guys grown stuff so
i just wanted to you know give my props
eventually but for some reason
the chat thinks i'm really they really
wanted me to get on over like
hey do you how often do you shower how
was your bo
because i feel like i might have someone
that you might that might
be compatible with you oh wow okay
so this is weird so like at first i just
have to shower like i'm gonna be honest
like
three times a day just to smell neutral
because
just because i'm like a large dude with
like a height and also i'm a fat boy
like i'm 380. so and i'm losing the
weight
so yeah like we all got problems man
what did you think about the
conversation we were having as a big boy
yourself
uh um do you do you sympathize with me
or am i being
over the top i i sympathize with
both sides honestly and i know that's
just trying to say that to be an h3h3
sim
because i do because like i do think
that it is a bit of an addiction and i
had
kind of a similar kind of problem
because like my mom she was like
super concerned for my health obviously
and so my dad like
my dad's overweight and my mom used to
be overweight but she actually
lost all the pounds and she's obviously
concerned for my health and at first
they were so on me about it like as if
like i hadn't done it and it's like
there'll be times where i'm like doing
really good and then for some reason
whether it's just
on a whim because maybe i'm impulsive or
maybe because i just felt the pressure
i kind of fell off the wagon but i feel
like as i got older
even like now like i'm starting to keep
it consistent
and it feels different from the rest and
i know i said that a few times but it's
like
i don't know like over time like i just
started getting kind of sick and sick of
it
and i think it's also a mixture kind of
learning to like love myself and like
just knowing that you know i i am
deserving of like
a good change like that and willing to
put in the effort
so what is right i agree with you but i
also kind of agree with you
because sometimes you do need those like
extra steps and kind of that support but
some of that can be overbearing you know
well should
uh what's the most annoying thing about
being fat for you
because i have a fear
well man dude i think the insecurity
problems because like
i was also sometimes when people like
aren't attracted to you because like you
know
me like i gotten i gotten over that like
where like now i kind of have confidence
in myself but
dude you know i'm not getting any right
swipes on tinder anytime soon so
it's a bit of a bummer i understand well
that girl the girl we spoke to sniff you
sounds like you're you're the perfect
guy for her but for me it's
the fact that my my thighs rubbed dude
straight up guys i feel that bro
i can't handle the thigh rubbing the
chaffing
all that [ __ ] is out of focus i feel
that yeah like
right now my room has like no windows so
i feel it like
hardcore all right av let's lose some
weight together what do you say let's do
it
i'm i'm down dude like i'll get to i'm
aiming for 300 so if you want to make a
goal
i'm gonna hit the peloton i'm gonna hit
the peloton tonight all right
yeah no let's let's do it man like i've
been on let's get some mayonnaise on on
dan's head all right
yeah i know i definitely want to get
mayonnaise on its head
okay thank you avery take care let's
we'll hear from you again we'll check in
a little bit more when we've got more
time but uh merry christmas definitely
yeah happy hanukkah dude god bless you
his last name's christmas by the way
that's why
okay do you have any last words for
keemstar who's saying we have marital
problems
i'll put my snacks in a secret drawer
and we'll see what happens no but
and he can report on that he's gonna
report on
on the snack uh yeah so keemstar just so
you know the key the snacks are going in
a drawer
uh our marriage is very healthy and
beautiful i love my wife and uh
people are saying get a food safe well
now that's pathetic
but it's a good idea
i mean that's kind of what i was trying
to say i feel a little pathetic having
no pathetic for me
it's pathetic for me not you for both of
us
you want me to have like a hidden evil
what's the what's the combination i get
it
do i also have to hide from you when i
eat it too no that's part of the problem
what's the cobo i need an
oreo [ __ ] marlon brando uh when he
tried to lose weight he used to chain
his fridge like with a
lock and key and his wife had it so
there's this old story that he took a
shotgun one night to the fridge to get
it
that's [ __ ] crazy
i totally believe that that kind of
[ __ ] nut
you're telling me that the fridge is
locked and i can't get uh
some meat and cheese let's not get into
this
guys this has been an episode two of the
h3
after dark live it's been a fun time
it's been a great time i've loved being
here and sharing it with you we've had a
lot about eyes we've had loads
um and everything in between really
haven't we but it's been a great time
thank you thank you to everyone who
donated thank you thank you thank you
big thank you to all of our sponsors it
does it means so much to us
uh to deliver the best possible product
to you guys
four episodes per week coming soon that
i can promise
okay and with that being said i hope you
guys have a great weekend kodiko
is going up on monday and uh
already up for members already up for
members so a lot of you guys have
already
been able to watch it but uh hey h3
podcast forever
they said we never return and uh they
might be right
we'll we'll find out on monday all right
guys i'm hungry
all right thanks for watching bye
everybody
[Music]
you